hello I'm Mike Huckabee and I'm here on  the campus of Hillsdale College you know  it's no surprise that in our schools  today the idea of objective morality is  under siege too many of our children are  being taught that it's hopeless to  define a right way as opposed to a wrong  way to live and their only guide in life  are their feelings well there have been  few people in all of history who have  argued more effectively against moral  relativism than CS Lewis let me invite  you to Hillsdale colleges free online  course an introduction to CS Lewis  taught by Hillsdale College President  dr. Larry Arn and his distinguished  panel you'll discover why this prolific  author is widely considered the greatest  Christian apologist of the modern era  go to Hillsdale dot edu slash CS Lewis  that's Hillsdale dot edu slash CS Lewis  and sign up for this free course today